bonsoir julien bonsoir merci d'être à la
première de bain de minuit est ce que tu
sais quel choix du moment absolument pas
on est sûr la cinquième chaîne et
beaucoup de chaleur marijuana trop y en
a trop on trouve moi je suis perdu mais
il ya plus d'émissions peu de chanteurs
mais oui et puis les stars c'est vous
c'est bien connu maintenant on verra le
plus criant nous les ongles et stable
alors on s'est connus aux bains douches
c'est ça le truc
alors on se connaît aux bains douches à
jets pour ça que j'ai voulu que tu
fasses la première émission est ce que
tu sais que le 14 septembre c'est
l'enregistrement de la première de ban
minuit mais c'est aussi une date
extrêmement importante est ce que tu
t'en souviens un petit village encore
une certaine virginie couperie
bonsoir tient souffle déjà trois cafés
comme cadeau pour ton mariage et nous en
met d'accord notre direct bah il peut te
laisser le micro à la fin de l'émission
fait non non je pense pas je pense qu'il
faudrait bien quelque chose dont je
parle le faire devant vous pas devant
tout le monde
est-ce qu'il est toujours aussi gentil
qu'il ya deux ans il vient aux gains de
plus souvent avec toi le plus souvent
tout seul avec moi moi alors je viens tu
donnes ton avis sur beaucoup de choses
là en charente à vue à 7 sur 7 a fait
une chanson sur la peine de mort et puis
beaucoup de beaucoup de chanteurs
s'exprime sur les tas de sujets et notre
ami finkielkraut et notre ami bernard
henri lévy ont fait tout un débat pour
dire que maintenant c'est un peu dommage
quand même ce soit les les chanteurs qui
parlait plus les philosophes alors
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi moi je
suis un peu de leur avis c'est un peu de
leur avis ouais mais ce t'empêche pas de
béton à vie pour même chose si on nous
le demande
alors je te demande comme annie sur ce
qui se passe en nouvelle calédonie par
exemple pendant mon avis parce qu'un
demi pourquoi je n'ai pas la solution du
problème est d'abord en nouvelle
calédonie tu penses pas que le sens de
l'histoire c'est quand même la nouvelle
qu'elle y soit indépendante un jour ou
l'autre je pense que
il ya eu des écrits là dessus quand
quelqu'un dit des choses beaucoup mieux
que moi et le pen qui dit que les
chambres à gaz c'est pas important tu en
penses quoi ça vous devriez poser la
question tout à l'heure à notre
prochaine invité quelques excellentes
réponse je veux pas la lui prendre
puisque si jamais vous l'aviez poser
ainsi qu'au corps qu'il sera prêt il
fera sûrement assez vite vous en trouver
une autre
mais enfin si tu mens indécent que j'ai
pas la vie vous donnez là dessus je
descends tu donnes pas ton avis sur les
sur les faits de société cette année
c'est pas ça enfin j'étais un peu après
après un jugement paraît trop indécent
gpad aviez donné c'est la révolte
je vais pas me mettre à brno tu veux
qu'on parle du rex alors si vous en
passant en passant c'est qu'en fait
comme chez drucker alors c'est quand les
horaires sans janvier de 12 ans le 12
janvier pour combien de temps pour un
mois et demi un mois et demi
et pourquoi tu as choisi le rex ça
change de bercy
quand tu sais que la nuit il ya des gens
formidables pulsé parce que tu sois pas
mal la nuit qu'elle est photographe qui
font des photos alors nous a bien de
minuit au malin qui s'appelle sylvain
bergère qui a fait des reportages pour
nous toutes les semaines et on va voir
le premier reportage sur notre machine
elle te plaît notre machine je la
mettrais dans ta salle de bal en machine
n'en fait jamais trop apparent des
salles de bains a été fait par un
artiste qui s'appelle protégeant bien
géré montera par le malheur c'est que ma
femme en les scrabbleurs alors on va
regarder le reportage de sylvain bergère